[Music]
and not all heroes wear capes news
mm-hmm keep going
submitted by show me the moolah mm-hmm
an off-duty pilot on vacation with his
family I had to step up to fly a plane
after the original pilot failed to show
up oh I feel like that's not a hero I
feel like I wouldn't like that if
they're if he's in the plane and then
the pilot dies and then this dude stays
a plane hero yeah what if the planes on
the ground now you're just putting
everybody's life at risk that's
different or what if they needed to get
somewhere if it's an emergency they
gotta get something either like come on
man it's Christmas I got a place to get
to home waiting for you yeah so this is
actually this dad steps in to fly plane
to Spain after original pilot delay so
at the actual airport they told some of
the customers and they let them know
ahead of time like hey we can't find
your pilot but don't worry one of the
passengers is a pilot this is a cook
this is a commercial flight yeah this is
a regular I'm hopping on Southwest
insured and he's liable and he's all
that stuff you just have a license and
you're like don't worry about it here
license that's a dumb and Dumberer Isaac
don't worry I'm a limo driver or how
long duty is he like straight up
unrelated to the airline or is it
Southwest flight Danny's off duty
southwestern is riding back home I
thought no that's fine he's on it said
he was on summer vacation so I'm like
okay is he maybe he's a China Airlines
pilot it is just like cross good jobs
like that sketch Leonardo DiCaprio and
catch me if you can they tell me if they
tell me and then I could choose like no
take my money back that's cool I'll take
my money back here or if you could
choose to go on no I know but I'm saying
if you don't tell me and I just hop on
this thing is that hey this is Dave on
vacation I'm gonna be taking you home
today oh yeah beep so this is how
basically went this this pilot he's I
guess he is on vacation or something
he's like straight up chillin and this
is so weird to me before going through
airport security maybe this is pilot
culture okay before going through
airport security
he calls he like called them and was
like hey do you guys need me for any
thing but hey that makes it sound like
your example like he works for them
yeah I was thinking he kidnapped pilot
he's like hey you guys need me thinking
that I'll take it like at all duty
firemen like hey heard there's a fire a
big fire going on I just feel like for
me it makes more sense that he works for
the company but I think the headline
just wanted to make it seem like he did
it they're like dad steps in to fly an
off-duty pilot they don't like connect
him at all to the actual thing but so
like he calls them insecurities like
before he's leaving he's like hey I
really want to go on a holiday do you
guys need me for anything so I feel like
he has to know you know so it says how I
phoned up easy Jen said hiya I'm
standing in the terminal doing nothing
and I'm very much like if you need a
favor I'm standing here ready to go and
they say like um yeah we'll phone you
right back and then it's just 38 seconds
later they said please please PLEASE
with a really big cherry on top could
you please find the airplane to Alicante
maybe he just wanted to go on a trip
exactly what's a free place yeah I mean
it seemed like yeah it is what it seems
like yeah I guess you've just got his
license and he's like oh no my again
that's true when I got my driver's
license I was like dad could I take the
car I'll just drive I
has he ever flown occur a commercial a
passenger plane yeah it's all sketchy
dude I wonder if there's like different
levels like there's a car you know you
have to get like different and what
they're definitely there definitely is
yeah I got there's a little Cessna
there's a Provost no there's a bunch of
her stuff the only time I'd feel
comfortable if he was like a [ __ ]
straight out like Air Force or a hike
lot like that's what a lot of those
commercial guys are if they're like
super level guys I'm just like y'all
[ __ ] poof c-130s and [ __ ] before
that's the only reason I have some kind
of like okay flying like I don't like
flying I get a little anxiety I think
everybody gets a little scary cuz that's
weird like just a little thought like
alright we could go down by never got
there not even at once
I love flying I don't mind it that's why
it's so crazy to me what I feel it's
like with crazy well I've had some bad
turbulence um like this might be like
skidded and [ __ ] like in the air was
like ah Colorado oh yeah I just know
column we landed like this we landed
like this it's in Colorado not really
yeah it does so most crashes happen
during takeoff or landing so ever since
I found that out I'm terrified of
takeoff the only thing that gives me
confidence is most of the commercial
guys are ex Air Force guys and so is
just super [ __ ] low compared to a car
yeah true
that's why rationalizing it I feel like
being in the car is a lot more scarier
the statistics are skewed because of the
how common it is we get in a car five
times a day we're gonna airplane what
some to think of statistics what it's
like I took a long over ride last night
to get to their house I got the wrong
place you know and you hear on the news
all the time weird things happening in
uber and I'm like a pretty big dude I'm
whatever fine 190 so I shouldn't really
be scared but every time I get in a car
I'm like man this does total stranger
like total stranger like this feels
weird and then pilots total stranger you
don't even see them you know can't even
see them no more they used to have the
door open you know I don't want to see
you let me see you at the end before
9/11 they had the door open you look in
there they let kids sit in the cockpit
and [ __ ] there's like totally normally
see you at the end maybe and they stand
there and they say thank you if you make
it you the doorman is done you should
have made it each time I mean yeah it
used to be way different update guys I
read another article I found another one
this is an actual easyJet pilot okay the
article tried to like make it seem like
he wasn't because they were saying like
I asked the guide the desk what's going
on he said oh your pilot's got busy
but that guy over in aisle 15 is gonna
fly your plane like that's kind of what
they told people and he were seeing
luckily the guy was actually a pilot
probably would have been cancelled
without him what a legend and I'm like
bro he doesn't works there now it's less
cool and I don't want to be that guy but
like there are some real [ __ ] heroes
going around in the world and like
that's not a hero to me like a delayed
plane isn't life or death yeah you know
what I mean there's some there's some
world you know there's cops there's
tyranny and there's military there's
dads that are saving their own kids
somehow dude I just saw a whole
compilation right now on Twitter Oh
[ __ ] dad's coming to the rescue of
like [ __ ] like baseballs coming
you've seen pets saving kids like
populations of pets or pets dated pets
dogs and cats there's this dog saving
this other dog from drowning I've
grabbed it by the neck I pulled it out
it was the cutest thing I've ever seen
Twitter's do really good for stuff like
that yeah I saw a bunch of dog stable
another bunch of dogs on a canoe that's
dope dog was canoeing and he came upon
some drowning dogs I love dad reactions
now and dad jokes like as I get older I
hate good I love it I love it so much
our dad jokes puns cuz if so I didn't
want a pun but there could be witty puns
that aren't dead jokes but a lot of dead
jokes right new puns are witty
like really simple jokes I don't know my
good giveaways just drops off your food
and it's like how's everything and they
like well I don't know I haven't had it
yet or some [ __ ] like oh my god that's a
bad one but like this stupid like that
okay can you finish all the food at the
restaurant the way just like how was it
and then you send it better
terrible dad does that and they all
think they're so [ __ ] original it's
so funny funny I know I know I'm being
lame I think gods do to kondeh no way
just heard it probably 15 to 40 times
that night tippers like some on guys I
just feel like for years and I never got
to hear any dad jokes really or maybe I
didn't appreciate them but I did not
this one time we're like this old man
he's like so I worked at Hooters he
that's why yeah you got Fridays too and
I didn't get any da jokes missus old man
he's like 70 and like he's got his son
with him it were like his grandson or
something he's like a young kid and so I
bring him a girl I bring him like
chicken and like then it's like bread on
the side and then I was like how's
everything looking can I get you guys
everything else in because the kid was
there he like pulls me in and he was
like why don't you go on and slather
yourself up with some butter and get on
between these two pieces of toast in
church and then she's like so what I was
working on Hooters sounds like a sexual
harassment dad jokes that's what I got
out of maybe it is the restaurant maybe
it is the restaurant loving yourself up
between some blow I kind of wish only
for like a week that guy's got cat
called like that oh you guys would love
it for a week out would love it my whole
life I probably sick of it just like you
guys when I'm the older lady I will
definitely hit on ya
you imagine all of the girls I'm
uncomfortable we're just at the park we
could barely walk anymore we're like
come here baby we want to get up in
there guys we're so thirsty for
attention we would love it now yeah Oh
ugly girls come from at 40 because it's
when it's starting 40 is a cool stop
lumping me into your old top 20 that's a
cougar oh it's the ratio what about 30
what about 32 18 cougar grilling cooler
yeah I don't think it's a cougar I think
you get some silver fox going before
you're 30
so you who make a cat call at a 20 year
old your coop now yeah we know you a
bobcat yeah there's like there's
different tiers there's a bobcat there I
said what I said I feel like they had to
start getting gray before they could be
a cougar that's what I thought no Silver
Fox that's it so when they're 80 they're
a slob they're totally silver but I'm
saying like to be a cougar I thought
maybe you need a little gray and I know
that happens I got Grandma years yeah
that's what's fun about it did you just
get the hit on you and watching the
other women I already know nothing yeah
I treat my boyfriend like a piece of
meat already I already know what am I
forgetting man hit on one I just don't
want to [ __ ] one like it's like a cool
little ego boost yeah attention she's
packing though
you ready she's got years of experience
yeah for sure mm-hmm experiences it
probably and like imagine like an older
super confident woman that knows that
you as a little 25 year old man or just
right in between unity knows she's
confident she know but she looks like a
[ __ ] bag of raisins yeah guys are too
visual for that girls at all I'm not
gonna [ __ ] a dehydrated proof I think
there's a lot of girls I think there's a
lot of girls that are in the how also
gotta be rich then yeah really funny
like oh this guy's so attractive they're
like little his wallet is attracted
sometimes like people say like whatever
George Clooney like oh when I'm thinking
cougar I'm thinking over 64 women I was
seeking over 50 a George Clooney's hi I
would read it's gotta be able to Brad
Pitt yeah he's over 50 it's the way he
they talked to you they gotta have some
charm like some charisma all charismatic
charming dude good job I just think
dudes can add you're better than women
sometimes to a girl so I compared to a
guy so I'm just saying what I made a
tender I made my max age 43
well thanks getting out there like 40 43
is like right on the edge I just made
sure we all porters 40 but just trying
to give you yeah yeah exactly
there we go I know
[Music]
[Music]